es un dolor de cabeza político que acaba
de empeorar para la administración biden
un segundo conjunto de archivos
clasificados se han encontrado en un
lugar no revelado esto se produce días
después de que la casa blanca confirmara
que en las antiguas oficinas del
presidente en el centroiden sus abogados
encontraron documentos clasificados en
un armario cerrado en una cumbre en
México el mandatario abordó el tema
Me informaron sobre Este descubrimiento
Y me sorprendió saber que había
registros del gobierno que fueron
llevados a esa oficina he entregado las
cajas han entregado las cajas y estamos
colaborando plenamente
apenas unas horas antes de que se
conociera la noticia sobre la segunda
serie de documentos la oficina de prensa
de la Casa Blanca desvió las preguntas
sobre la investigación en curso el
departamento de Justicia ha nombrado un
fiscal de Chicago para que examine la
posible filtración Y compruebe si sea
infringido alguna ley sin embargo la
reacción política no se ha hecho esperar
en relación con el motivo sobre que los
documentos nos encontraban en el archivo
nacional ahora se están formando
paralelos en relación con la
investigación en curso a Donald Trump y
su negativa a entregar documentos
clasificados y por lo tanto obligar al
FBI a incautarlos de su casa en Florida
algo que va a ir en tildo de
irresponsable para el líder de los
republicanos en la cámara de
representantes se trata de una doble
moral
porque su departamento de Justicia Trata
a la gente de manera diferente cada vez
que encontramos algo que sale antes de
las elecciones en relación con la
familia de biden se mete bajo la
alfombra se dice que es mentira que los
rusos lo están haciendo Y ahora por qué
tratan al presidente Trump totalmente
diferente la gravedad de las
investigaciones y la forma en que ambos
presidentes las han manejado son muy
diferentes pero el descubrimiento de
biden podría proporcionar un salvavidas
para los republicanos este podría
mitigar los problemas de Trump mientras
la reputación de biden se ve